you did a show in Reno this weekend I
understand yes I did how did it go it
went great it was just you know big show
everything went great and then one
person I was making fun of the military
you know which you can't do now like we
totally went the from Vietnam all the
hippies mean like hey man you like a
baby killer man to like now you got to
give like a standing ovation when they
walk over to Delta you don't even show
that you're not an Isis like I don't
know what so I do this bit making fun of
the military a little bit and the first
time I did it I did it at a VFW to make
sure that it was funny in the right way
and a kilt was even dude he lost his
legs he almost fell out of his chair
going dude that is so true so they
weren't you got approval from a federal
that I'm doing it in front of regular
people you know what it means so the
second up everybody has a good time with
it except one person he came all the way
up to the front and just starts he
didn't even heckle just start yelling
sir yeah show some respect yelling at me
like he's my dad right so he's like a
hundred pounds overweight I'm like why
don't you show some respect and lose a
little weight next time you have the
middle seat on a flight you won't be
spilling over at people like heroes hero
now everyone's a hero I'm gonna tell you
what about fat people your organs are
not giving you a standing ovation as you
walk over to the refrigerator again what
you're doing is dangerous you got
children lay off
it's so brave it's so brave to be out of
that you know so whatever so that guy up
god I was so upset that security like
escorted him out I wanted to talk like I
started my show blaming women for sexual
harassment that's how I started yes it
was late cert I wasn't being serious
your children this is the worst time I
ever did now move my chair away from you
it's literally now as a comedian yeah
it's like the walls it's like you're in
this walk-in closet of what could be
funny and meanwhile there's like a swirl
a trash with every toothbrush he ever
used spinning around the Pacific Ocean
nobody cares god forbid you tease the
Navy a little bit and people have liked
it like a conniption well what did you
say about the military that got people
so mad or this one guys I was just
saying like yeah the guy who flies the
fighter jet okay and has missiles shot
and that guy is a hero however if you're
the guy that like points in the
direction that the plane takes off and
[Applause]
you don't think that guy the guy who
points in the direction is yeah there's
I doing warrior one like the yoga pose
like the battlefield is that way
no but everything has just become that
it's just become like this this you know
that whole first-responder thing you
know all these like old words you have
to say it's so stupid I'm gonna First
Responder I love that one it's like dude
I called you I saw the fire
we just want to thank our first
responders it drives me up the wall
alright we're gonna take gonna take a
little break we'll have more with bill
burr we'll calm him down
during the
[Applause]
you